well let me also ask you about something
that you found especially recently
appealing which is roger penrose's
twister theory
um what is it what kind of questions
might it allow us to answer
what will the answers look like it's
only in the last couple years i really
really kind of come to really i think to
appreciate it and to see how to really
what i i believe to see how to really do
something with it and i've gotten very
excited about that the last year too i
mean one way of saying
one idea of twister theory is that what
it's it's it's a different
way of thinking about
what space and time are and about what
points in space and time are
but but which only which is very
interesting that it only really works in
four dimensions so four dimensions
behaves very very specially unlike other
dimensions and in four dimensions
there's certain
there is a way of thinking about
space and time geometry where you know
as well as just thinking about
points in space and time you can also
um
think about different objects it's all
called twisters and then when you do
that you end up with a um kind of a
really interesting insight that the um
that
you can formulate a theory and you can
formulate a very take a standard theory
that we formulated in terms of points of
space and time and you can reformulate
in this twister language and in this
twister language it's the um
the fundamental objects are actually are
more kind of the
are actually spheres in some sense kind
of the light cone so maybe one
way to say it which actually i think is
really
is quite amazing is if you ask yourself
you know what do we know about about the
world we have this idea that
the world out there is this all these
different points in these points of time
well that's kind of a derived quantity
what really really know about the world
is when we we open our eyes what do you
see
you see a sphere
and you and that what you're looking at
is you're looking at this you know a
sphere is worth a light rays coming into
your into your eyes and what penrose
says is that
well what what a point in space-time is
is that sphere
that sphere of all the light rays coming
in and and he says and you should
formulate your um instead of thinking
about points you should think about the
space of those spheres if you like and
formulate the degrees of freedom as
physics as living on those fears
living on so you're kind of you're kind
of living on your degrees of freedom are
living on light rays not on points
and it's a very different way of
thinking about um
about about physics and you know he and
others working with him developed a
you know a beautiful mathematical this
beautiful mathematical formalism and a
way to go back and forth between our
kind of some aspects of our standard way
we write these things down and
work in the so-called twister space and
you know they
certain things worked out very well but
they ended up
you know
i think kind of stuck by the 80s or 90s
that they
weren't a little bit like string theory
that they they um
by using these ideas about twisters they
could develop them in different
directions and find all sorts of other
interesting things but they were they
were getting they weren't finding any
way of doing that that brought them back
to kind of new insights into physics
and um my own i mean what's kind of
gotten me excited really is is that what
i think i have an
idea about
that i think does actually does actually
work that goes more in that direction
and um i can go on about that endlessly
or tell you a little bit about it but
that's the um
i think that that's the one kind of easy
to explain insight about twister theory
there are some more technical ones
actually i think it's also very
convincing what it tells you about
spinners for instance but that's a more
technical well first let's like linger
on the spheres and the light cones
you're saying twisted theory allows you
to
make that the fundamental object with
which you're operating yeah
how that i mean first of all like
philosophically that's
weird
and beautiful
maybe because it maps
it feels like it moves us so much closer
to
the way human brains perceive reality
yeah so it's almost like um
our perception is
like the the content of our perception
is the fundamental object of reality
that's very appealing yeah
is it mathematically
powerful
is there something you can
say
can you say a little bit more about what
the heck that even means uh for because
it's much easier to think about
mathematically like a point in space
time like what does it mean to be
operating on the light cone
it uses a kind of mathematics that's
relative that you know what was kind of
goes back to the 19th century among
mathematicians it's not um
anyway it's a bit of a long story but
one problem is that you have to start
it's crucial that you think in terms of
complex numbers and not just real
numbers and
this for most people that makes it
harder to for mathematicians that's fine
we love doing that but for most people
that makes it harder to think about
you